hello you're playing the waiting game
the video game recommendation shows that
strong-armed in a new presenter me said
forward but what it's lost in beards
it's made up for in current progressive
humor how about that airplane food might
well Christ this week we're taking a
look at the time altering anarchy of
quantum break the xbox one exclusive to
out later this year from remedy those
had some folks who brought you the time
altering Max Payne and the time altering
max payne 2 also they made Alan Wake
quantum break sees a time travel
experiment go disastrously wrong in
doing so giving our heroes Jack Joyce
and Beth Wilder the ability to
manipulate time along with evil doer and
all-round bad guy Paul serene your
choices in game playing as Joyce and
Wilder will decide how your particular
timeline progresses with bad guys to
means power allowing him to see
alternate timelines on top of that
remedy have said how you play the game
impacts the show and the show informs
how you play the game oh yeah they're
also making a quantum break TV show to
accompany the game featuring this creepy
kid and this hot mum do you think it's
safer going yeah paid 92 but without a
solid release date for the time bending
game or yummy mummy series 1 what is
there to sink your teeth into while you
pass the time travel sorry it's been a
long time let's get on with this oh oh
god oh god it's been a long time since I
crunched first up there's adjustment
team a short science fiction story by
philip k dick you know you're right it
does sound a lot like the adjustment
bureau be reasonably watchable matt
damon film well as because the movies
based on that original text within we
meet ed Fletcher orb David Norris if you
chose the film who's running a minute
later for work than he should be causing
him to arrive to an ash gray office
frozen in time to see
the adjustment team of men busy working
around his static colleagues the team is
there to make subtle changes to the
world we know in order to spark a chain
of events later down the line to prevent
worldly disasters of course as far as
Fletcher's concerned he's probably just
gone a bit mental or has he read the
book and find out why not you know or
watch the film emily Blunt's in that and
she's lovely you could also play braid
you see manipulating time doesn't have
to be all explosions and crying and
bleeding and screaming sometimes you can
just run around with a little waistcoat
okay playing with time always results in
bleeding and death but in braids you can
reverse time and take another swing at
whatever foolish mistakes or you meet
your premature demise at its heart it's
a puzzle platformer that will have you
pounding your head against your monitor
in frustration but will also make you
feel like some kind of time wizard once
you've got it all figured out there are
six worlds to visit each with its own
time mechanic to master for example
moving your smartly dressed hero Tim to
the right progress is time for words
while left reverses figure that out time
wizard this adorable title from indie
game designer Jonathan Blow has been
around for well over five years so it's
hardly hot off the press but to this day
it's still known as one of the finest
arcade titles of last gen
now time travel is a fun little hook
used in TV that has this amazing power
to cancel shows usually because they're
awful did you ever see journey man it
was genuinely awful and I'm not
recommending it don't watch journey man
just to be clear
flash forward on the other hand is
pretty decent despite again suffering
the one season curse almost everyone on
the planet falls unconscious for two
minutes and 17 seconds in that moment
they'd catch a glimpse of their lives in
six months time when the blackout
happened and the entire world saw the
future we all wondered would our visions
come true mark Benford must spearhead an
FBI operation to determine what happened
to the planet whether it'll happen again
and why one person suspect zero was the
only one unaffected the reason he's in
charge is because his flash-forward
showed him the results of that six-month
investigation bit of a paradox I know
but day TV meanwhile others see
themselves with new partners and some
see nothing at all maybe they'll be dead
maybe their destiny isn't set maybe
you'll give it a watch maybe you won't
either way it only ran for one season so
it's a small time investment compared to
that lost oh no the numbers piss off we
have to go back oh no you don't travel
back with me now to beginning of the
show when I mentioned Max Payne and the
time altering max payne 2 because they
made the list remedy has its own
particular brand of storytelling with
writer Sam lake at the helm all the way
through they even put his face on max
for the first game what I'm getting at
is in terms of matching the tone and
style of quantum break you'd do very
well to check out remedies previous
titles max payne in particular though
lay down a groundbreaking time mechanic
that's featured in all sorts of games
ever since bullet time as it's now
affectionately known gives the player a
temporary dose of slow motion allowing
you to accurately place shots and die
for cover when you're in a bit of a
pickle
while not strictly a time mechanic that
Max is where he has control of its still
at all you as a player will need to use
correctly and ration appropriately as
you go wrap that up in some gritty crime
thriller noir and you're in for a great
toast of quality gaming and much like
quantum break it also got a video
treatment alongside although years later
in the form of a blockbuster movie that
was so bad it actually made people in
the cinema die that's not true but I've
said it and I can't take it back because
I'm not the time isn't look I can see
that you think you know me but I don't
know who you are my name is Captain
Colter Stevens imagine waking up as
another person altogether on a train
only to have it explode and kill you
then imagine having to live that moment
over and over again in order to find out
why and how that explosion happens in
the 2011 film source code that's exactly
what happens to Captain Colter Stevens
play by notable cowboy Jake Gyllenhaal
trapped inside a tiny leaking cockpit
Stevens is forced against his will to
relive the memory of a compatible
commuter creating alternate timelines in
which the identity of the bomber may
eventually be found it's a gripping bit
of sci-fi and don't let the multitude of
explosions distract you from the
incredibly moving story line that runs
throughout it will leave you thinking
about time in a whole new light and
that's all I've got for you in this
episode but rest assured there are
plenty of time based stories to gorge on
in the lead-up to quantum break perhaps
you were expecting the butterfly effect
for example well it's not there that's
because Ashton Kutcher should stick to
comedy where he belongs what the [ __ ] is
hilarious do please let me know what you
will be watching reading and playing in
the meantime by tweeting at Ready Steady
Go and or using the hashtag GS waiting
game I'll be back next week with five
more suggestions to tide you over to
your favorite titles I'll see you then
you